hey everyone stick around to the end of
the episode to find out how you can get
some of our new apparel
and until then enjoy the episode the
clash between teenagers and parents
is nothing new parents just don't
understand but with the generation
brought up on technology and social
media
how well do parents actually know their
teenagers today
enough to blend in among teens how do
you do fellow kids
what to answer this question we brought
together six teens
and one secret parent with cameras and
mics off
words only can they find the undercover
parent
you're looking for people that use like
proper grammar maybe
or end their sentences with periods you
mentioned facebook
you're going home i guess i'll be pretty
observant with the way on how people
text
i'm canadian and like they're american
and there might be some slight
differences
i just i just hope my inner mom doesn't
come out you know
i love i love kids be honest
but not too honest
i'm a little worried because i'm in
college honestly if somebody
told me oh yeah i'm in college it'd be
like seems like you're compensating for
something
using tick-tock and social media and
vines and like i don't know pop culture
references is like a huge
plus in detecting them all literally
anything can be twisted like i could say
oh i really like this and some people
could think that i'm just lying
alec and charlie looking type sus real
quick no i can't cap
can't cap i'm just gonna be myself
i'm planning on just piggybacking off of
whatever they say i have teenagers
18 and a 15 year old so i pretty much
know
what to say what not to say what's in
what's not it and i'm not that old
i got it okay
[Music]
oh my goodness oh
i was so worried that they'd get like
younger teenagers
oh my gosh okay so people are mentioning
tick-tock straight tick-tock
wait i forgot to talk too wow they go
fast
i'm glad everyone's kind of like from
two
from like 2000 yeah from 2006 and before
that cool
okay so okay i trust
i chose here oh there's so many
questions
okay where am i
they're all talking about tick-tock but
i don't have tick-tock
okay so we got a lot of people from a
lot of different places
brooklyn alec is asking for favorite
tick-tockers and honestly that's kind of
weird
i don't have a favorite tick-tocker that
makes sense i just
i'd literally just watch
i ask for pronouns because might as well
i don't think people are on tick tock to
like follow people which is kind of like
weird
like the little cool things that they do
like that like i'll stop waffling like
i'm a waffler i'll stop
i'll start um oh my god dude i don't
even know what to ask like how do you
even
how do you even filter an adult
okay so i think i'm blending in my
strategy i think it's working i'm just
piggybacking off of what they say
i'm really not on tick tock so i have to
kind of see what's going on
okay so this is intense and there's like
no much time left
what's your favorite jayton
renegade renegade
i'm just looking at basically who
who is saying things that are just too
basic
johnny test yo i love johnny tess
bro i use that show every time to go to
sleep kid cat
interesting you don't use tick-tock
laurel i see you i'm not gonna do so
much going on
i think i got it guys see how this is
going hopefully they don't figure me out
i'm kind of slow
gosh the tick tock thing already got me
no no
no no no no okay oh my god
i don't remember i don't know what my
favorite childhood show
is like i looked whatever came on
television
okay this is actually intense
i carly sam was cute from that so
oh my gosh i'm sweating this is actually
intense
oh man
oh no that round was pretty chaotic
chaotic chaos tell me who you're voting
for
and why but my immediate suspicion right
now is laurel because laurel
was really good with her capitalization
laurel said that she wasn't
on tick tock actually laurel was my
first pick because of her bitmoji i do
not trust that
she looks like she's um i don't know a
40 year old mother i'm the most
suspicious about
alex it seems like he's just like trying
to follow the rest of the trends or
something like that
so yeah i wasn't supposed to be alec and
then he started singing to johnny test
can't cap
respect that i'ma vote for gabby i don't
know she's a little quiet just listening
i would vote brian there wasn't really
much content
that like he showed i'll keep an eye out
for charlie because charlie's giving me
some parent vibes we know it's not
charlie he's always in here chatting
i'm kind of piggybacking off of him i'm
a little bit suspicious of
kaya the first person eliminated
please don't be mean is
gabby
oh it's so disappointing i kind of saw
it coming
so a lot of questions i didn't get the
chance to respond to i'm still in here
i told you guys i'm young i got this i'm
taking this all the way to the end
trust me all right here we go round two
oh my god
okay so it's round two let's go back at
it again with the white man
[Music]
okay maybe it's not grinding they're
asking about ap
questions but ap seminar i took
two weeks to
be more organized okay so
laurel oh alec is coming for laurel and
asking if she can name
three vine stars i'm getting to that
portion of now where i'm
where i am i'm just trying to feel
yeah i'm just trying to filter out
people now she said that
what three vine stars king batch
road work okay she's only naming like
iconic vines
nah mostly just watch king match he's
the only one that got popping
so i'm i'm just gonna let them know but
they are kind of toxic oh my gosh
okay okay i'm i'm not as suspicious as
laurel
okay let me ask brandon a question now
brandon
can you i'm asking brandon what a streak
is
to see uh if he can like tell me
whether it's from snapchat or whether
it's from like
some other definition for street you
know what i mean these aren't actually
getting on each other
who is y'alls your artist i thought i
already went over this
um anybody this is okay so
the chat is kind of dying but i think
it's just because we have a lot of
questions like
popping up and nobody really knows what
to say
um
so i already know you over here over
here account for me
who asked me that question that's okay
so
um everybody's writing down
i'm gonna miss kickbacks what is a
kickbacks
i don't know what a kick i think this is
a party
[Music]
i think i got him guys with the homies
charlie
what's that am i dumb what's that i'm
dumb
never heard about it you call it
chilling in brooklyn
oh man i never i'm so i don't even know
what to do
i don't know who to suspect like i feel
like i'm vibing with
everybody uh okay i'm just asking
individual specific questions now just
so i can
dr doofenshmirtz kia finish the sentence
yeah they're really getting on each
other for anything
i can't even what the heck
dude what do i even say i'm just trying
to ask specific questions to people
oh my gosh kia where are you girl
what uh oh my goodness
looks evil
and poor how are you going to court
[Music]
all right i i don't think brandon's it
i don't think bonnie's it
[Music]
i think quia isn't it because she knew
what all tick-tock wore
was the girl was like saved adam 2020.
she has to
she has to be a teenager i think i love
your guy's favorite music growing up
please baby
i was bopping to battered hands we see a
baby
the f is for you to find out
oh man oh man i don't even know what to
do
everybody had an email face that's like
that's actually
we don't talk about her what
you know okay i'm making sure to like
drop down any references that i have
right now
bastion he is just gone
he is gone
[Music]
oh wait i was about to type in poop but
in swear word
i got sense for myself
okay who's not talking kai is not
talking hmm what about tv shows
that was so tragic yikes bonnie seems
good
charlie seems good okay so bonnie's
talking about her middle school
experience
but right now kia is silent
oh should i answer my individual
questions
um i've never heard of that
is this an american thing i don't want
to comment i don't want to
kia because she's not saying anything
tv shows oh man lucky i hate 13 machines
it's toxic it's true i do okay
oh wait i didn't even see wait
i didn't even they all talking about 13
reasons why i didn't see the new season
yet
don't ruin it strength uh sucks
[Music]
even have netflix i'm broke
okay so um everybody's talking but the
only person that doesn't seem to be
speaking up as much is kia
that's tough i could use i couldn't use
apps my dad was pretty sure
so kia's saying that she couldn't use
apps
no i'll be on disney channel i'll be on
disney plus
you're good i grew up i'm like family
guy and southpaw
and one minute remaining that's not
harley
i mean okay if i was to go this way like
who i can trust
i can definitely trust charlie i can
trust kia
um she's not really like speaking up
that much and there was like a period of
time in the chat where she didn't say
anything and that's just super weird
she's saying she has netflix
i don't know what to ask i continue to
think it's kia
or laurel maybe brandon but i'm starting
to not be as suspicious of brandon
i'm just trying to like stay relevant in
the chat right now i can't go under as
being the suspicious
person charlie is coming for me again
that's tough that's tough
i have no idea agg what is so
intense for who's the main character of
minecraft okay oh we're done
i came to this with this plan and the
plan to ask
individuals specific questions that did
not work
and now i have no clue who the mole is
alec
bro i don't know why you can't pressure
me can't you keep trying to comfort me
yo i feel like it's low-key toxic i'm
voting brandon again
i'm so sorry right now i have high
suspicions on kia and i think i'm gonna
vote for her because
alex which i'm now trusting asked what
is the end of the phrase like doc dude
schmutz evil incorporated and she didn't
respond
at all nothing and then she also said
that she couldn't use
apps because her dad was pretty strict
but that's just a defense for not saying
anything in the before rounds
sometimes her story was a little off
quia i'm sorry but you got my vote
kaya was quiet yeah i think i'm gonna go
for kia
so i'm voting charlie out of here he's
trying to figure me out and he's asking
all of these questions
by charlie you gotta go person who's
eliminated
in round two is
kia she got eliminated they figured me
out i think it was charlie that was
asking me
about dr duke and the tune i have no
idea what that is
i knew when charlie kept pressing for
the answer and i didn't know the answer
i knew that they would go ahead and vote
me out
[Music]
for this next round you will have one
minute to submit your favorite tick tock
or name in the chat after the minute is
up
we'll review everyone's submissions and
you'll cast your vote
based off their submissions ready
i'm going so fast this is actually so
intense
oh no that means i gotta look it up now
[Music]
i can only think of like 2017 lines
right now because i wanted to post
this other one but it it's not pg-13 i
gotta keep it actually
i don't think it worked oh shoot
somebody put a tumbler thing
oh how do these people have ted talks on
standby is what i don't understand
ready spell corn backwards go
nroc dang let me finish
now what's the best vegetable in the
market uh no rock
it's not in rock it's corn
okay bonnie's video is so funny and i
actually really like that video
okay that one's good i still trust
bonnie i didn't really
get it weird
it wasn't weird that was it
oh everybody stay calm oh that was what
she was trying to send
that meme five out of ten everybody stay
calm
oh my god it's happening girl laurel's
putting
office stuff there's something okay
let's see what alex said
oh wait look at all these chickens
i know this meme it's okay
look at all those chickens it's a
classic
i levitated
the one about nicki minaj it wasn't
really funny okay this is brandon's i'm
watching it right now it's a ticket
jesus christ x bro what are you doing
here i was
charging yo i am also feeling quite
parched
i was wondering if i could get a sip of
your beverage
all these clips are good oh
that's my wi-fi right now also my
computer
brandon's video is like pretty much our
generation
and it's also on tick-tock jet mode
activated
let's go laurel
if like i had to choose one person it
would be her because
she put in a link to like some office
meme that's not really a tick tock lori
i don't know if i'm pronouncing her name
correctly
i'm voting for laurel i'm gonna go with
alec i think i'm gonna vote for alec
if somebody looked up classic vines
it would be like look at all those
chickens
and also i outed myself for using ecosia
which if anybody calls me up for using
ecosia
i'm just trying to reforest the world
okay don't come for me
i'm disappointed i thought that i was
starting to get into the groove of
it it was just i wish that i had like
been
more myself i don't know but at least my
computer no longer sounds like an
airplane
go ahead and put in the main chat if you
want to continue the game because you
think the ball is still in the group
[Music]
okay majority wins we're going to keep
going
bonnie's the only one that said no
i don't think we got the most i don't
think so the reason why i continued is
mainly because of peer pressure because
i saw two people
put a thumbs up and i don't know if i
have any suspicions of
anybody we have five minutes which is
actually crazy
i don't know what to do oh
okay what is like something only our
generation can relate to
oh shoot that hit heart
he said for real for real right rip
juice i mean minecraft stuff no
that was that was a kosher reset
rpx to you right hold on
i p pop smoke
[Music]
minecraft scenes my life man said
culture reset i'm gone
uh i don't know oh
this is kind of hard i think we all
reeled out the mole
[Music]
oh sorry everybody just gonna ignore
what i said copy cool
cool
that's what's crazy is that like i'm
gonna be an adult next year i'm gonna be
graduating high school next year
and that's like super overwhelming and
like
brings me so much anxiety
that like i don't really know what to
think about that
i don't know i think we really reeled
out the mole
not gonna lie so much on a
side note by the way
i don't know either i feel so bad
oh we got him but it's hard i almost
just want to
vote for elise
bonnie bonnie
seems uh
bonnie seems like she's really good at
this dang game
[Music]
bonnie i feel like has proved that she's
a teenager
oh my gosh
[Music]
i love you i love you all
yeah why did we do this i'm so
actually like gonna cry i don't know
like i really think we got everyone can
i just close my eyes and pick who to
vote for
oh shoot i picked brandon oh i don't
want to vote for him again i feel so bad
for tithing him
but i guess that's how we're gonna roll
i'm voting for brandon
i have to i i charlie and bonnie have
just said
too much to make me believe that they're
a teenager i still
think alec is truly coming for me
he keeps asking me questions and then he
says
he's not directing it to me but it's
directed to me
my vote might come down to money
you know i just need i just need
something i think i'm gonna have to vote
for brandon but he seems like super nice
and he does seem like a teen
because alec i think is targeting him
already i just have to
i'm on the verge of tia the person
eliminated in this round
is brandon oh brandon got eliminated oh
my
god i knew it this sucks being honest
i feel like what messed me up was when
he asked me
what famous people and i didn't tell no
fans i just told him how we did it i
think everyone voted for me
guys we we can't go on
yeah everybody said no if the icon i
show you is green
you've caught them all in one if the
icon is red
you've failed three two
[Music]
[Applause]
one
[Music]
[Applause]
my camera is going crazy right now guys
what
and i was mad at charlie but it was alec
that figured me out and i
knew it i'm just like i should
that means i didn't need to get out i
didn't need to get out
i was fine
i had a really good experience i enjoyed
filming with all of the different teams
my communication it was not good i spent
too much time
talking to this camera if somebody was a
bit off of how i think high schoolers
should act i immediately
became suspicious of them and i think
that's really unhealthy because we
should have the space
allowed for teenagers to act however
they want without
feeling judgment from other teams i
think that there is kind of
the stereotype that like all teens care
about is
tick-tock and i don't know high school
drama and stuff
i don't think my parents would
understand this game enough or know how
to
talk or whatever they're not young
parents and if anything they are
immigrants because i'm a first
generation parents nah
i don't think you could beat this man
unless you're a freaking genius
unless you're on top of your game with
what's been going on in social media for
the last 15 years
good freaking luck dude i don't think
you got what it takes but
i did it you just watched all men out
hey guys thanks again for watching make
sure to check out drop two of our
merchandise including this awesome
hoodie at humangoodla.com
and use the code here to get a discount
the code will expire in 48 hours so make
sure to head there soon and we will see
you next time